gottardi de botar fé botar filhos uma
vida quer que desta platéia acredita que
o caminho para um mundo mais justo passa
pela igualdade de direitos deveres e
oportunidades entre homens e mulheres
quem acredita que 90 não sei espetáculo
só por ser a única não levantar do véu é
que quando chegou a primeira vez é
sempre um choque é uma coisa que pode
traumatizar através de dois até a gente
não tem que dizer não vemos no dia a dia
não variável
quero fazer contra 3 a 3 no 3321 todos
os que comandaram mann ministro sérgio
levantou não vou mesmo obrigada
são todos os ministros é esse mesmo
montante porque tem que fixar a primeira
coisa é que o feminismo é exatamente
essa igualdade de direitos
do universo de oportunidades para homens
e mulheres os mesmos direitos cívicos e
políticos importantes
é por isso que luta pela igualdade de
gênero tem que ser de todos os que estão
aqui nesta sala faz parte de uma
realidade que é realmente terrível e que
não pode ser escamoteada história provas
que é um génio tem sido oprimido é um
gênero feminino e é um gênero tem sido a
pessoa que é o gênero masculino e tem
muito desconfortável se ouvir nós
sabemos mas é também por isso que é tão
importante usar a palavra feminismo sem
qualquer espécie de tabu e feminista é
ter consciência dessa opção e é por isso
que o feminismo tem que ser um caminho
que tem de ser percorrido entre o com
homens e mulheres lado a lado
ter consciência dessa história da
história dessa opção e ter vontade para
entrar nessa história
todos juntos até porque se pensa pensa
agora comigo feminismo nunca matou
ninguém eo machismo mata todos os dias
pensa nisso
afinal trabalhada pela tua e usar o jogo
continuou pegado assim não é qual é
exemplo o segundo mas com que tem que
parecer um feminista ou uma feminista de
carência
imagine que em todos os formatos
mulheres homens e mulheres que se vê
pilão incrível é homens que se depilam
outros que não se pilão mulheres que
usam batom minissaia são os autos
mulheres que usam tênis short camisa aos
quadrados de homens que usam batom
minissaia saltos altos homens que usam
tênis jeans camisa aos quadrados
até porque essas cenas da imagem tem que
deixar de ser mas não é fácil mas é tudo
muito depressa
olha para a copa na ministra
beyoncé vai ministrar dois anos
o time está aqui está uma duvidosa
feminista outra maravilhosa ela é
feminista já não é johnny
cate blanchett feminista feminista e
podemos ficar aqui toda a manhã os
portugueses resumo não há uma farda pra
ser feminista feminista é acreditar na
igualdade de gênero e lutar por ela
todos os dias não se pode mexer a boca
pra dizer que somos feministas por que
agora muita culpa e feminista não é ser
ministra é um compromisso é uma atitude
precisa ser todos os dias
então a questão é por que falam tanto em
igualdade de gênero qual é a diferença
entre o sexo e gênero ou explicar que o
sexo é atribuído consoante o órgão
genital que detetado
neste momento o órgão genital um e
orientação sexual tem a ver com quem nos
sentimos sexualmente trilhos vai não vai
ver também o gênero é nossa identidade
sexual nos sentimos homens ou mulheres
tanto em um gênero está aqui na seleção
o sentido nada tem a ver com o que está
no meio das pernas nem com quem nos
crimes funcionais sexualmente esse
sentido só todas as listas
por isso é que ser feminista implicar
luta pela igualdade de direitos e
oportunidades para todas as pessoas
mulheres heterossexuais dez lésbicas
bissexuais e transgêneros de todas as
raças e todos os credos pessoas
estamos a falar de duas pessoas pessoas
todas diferentes mas todas com direito
aos direitos aos mesmos direitos e as
mesmas oportunidades e perguntou vocês é
tudo muito lindo e falamos então por que
raio é que é preciso falar em feminismo
nos dias de hoje que tem uma pergunta
como fazem todos os dias mas porque é
preciso ser feminista em portugal claro
que vocês vamos à concretos em portugal
no ano de 2014
não quero mais de 40 mulheres vítimas de
violência doméstica em 2015 já morreram
onze mulheres vítimas de violência
doméstica em portugal é violência no
namoro no outro lado aumentou 50% neste
último as mulheres a em portugal têm
ordenados mais baixos do que os homens
nas mesmíssimas funções das mulheres em
portugal sai em maior número das
faculdades têm melhores classificações e
continuam a não estar sentadas nos
conselhos de administração estão em
grande minoria dos casos uma mulher
solteira é em portugal não têm direito a
procriação médica assistida
um casal do mesmo sexo em portugal não
pode
acho uma criança em portugal as minhas
quando na rua já entre utilizaram como
sendo uma coisa normal ouviram as
maiores autoridades para totalmente
conhecidos
essa invasão absurda do nosso espaço é
uma violência é uma violência que
acontece todos os dias a mulher de todas
as idades acontece às vossas mais
aconteça as nossas filhas que tem apenas
12 anos e acreditem não é fiz não é
mesmo
em portugal há mulheres que são
mutiladas
esta é uma realidade muita gente conhece
mas é uma realidade é é terrível a
mutilação genital feminina e portanto
ela está escondida em portugal porque
existe e nós estamos aqui também para
denunciar em portugal uma mulher que era
ser mãe tem que pensar duas vezes para
não perder o emprego ou a oportunidade
de trabalho e podemos estar aqui mas não
sei quanto tempo mas não dá portanto
vários são os fatores nós duas temos a
oportunidade para estar aqui e fazer
esta conversa convosco para poder dizer
o que pensamos por que a mulher se houve
mulheres que lutaram que pensaram que
escreveram que legislaram direitos para
nós são dados adquiridos eu decidir eu
voltar pra começar a decidir sobre o meu
corpo por exemplo sobre a gravidez e
foram mulheres corajosas que arriscaram
já serviço né direções não não tiveram
medo
várias delas foi logo na primeira
república é de castro osório a do ipv6
turismo foram pioneiras na luta dos
direitos das mulheres em plena ditadura
de ditadura peço desculpa é maria teresa
horta maria velho da costa foram levadas
a tribunal por terem escrito um livro
onde anunciava a opção de aceitar as
mulheres no nosso país já depois do 25
de abril e mulheres que construíram e
continuam a construir todos os dias à
nossa igualdade em nossa liberdade disse
madalena barbosa maria antônia fala
maria de lurdes pintassilgo will
norueguesa e mais recentemente no
parlamento na caminha anos teve mais nos
a média de preço e pizarro beleza isabel
moreira a fernanda kessy e claro sou
meio entre tantas outras clima que está
lá estar também em grande parte do dia e
no horário mas nós podemos não se
importam para estas mulheres uma valente
salvas salva de palmas por foram elas
que nos abriram sobre o caminho é
marinho pareça tóquio
obrigada também quero dar o que não é
bom o que é certo é que apesar de todos
esses problemas que acabámos de numerada
até relativamente fácil ser mulher em
portugal mas o feminismo em defender
todas as mulheres e todos os homens e
todos os gases de todas as lésbicas e
pesava no braço
as mulheres ganharam grande perda porque
dará os seus direitos e sabemos muito
mas muito mais adquiridos sem fronteiras
não podemos olhar as fronteiras né
nós estamos aqui muito mas sim aquilo
que nos move é tal paixão que faz
acordar também vai às duas da manhã
não dormi até não dormir pra fazer
aquilo que eu acho que pode mudar o
mundo
nós temos aqui pra falar pra aquelas que
ao contrário de todas as outras que
estão aqui sentados nestas carreiras não
têm voz denunciar os crimes contra elas
com filhos votar por elas sem do nosso
confortável com umbigo europeu para um
desconforto o horror da condição
feminina no mundo
casamentos forçados de jovens mulheres
de minas acontece um pouco por todo
mundo mas na unicef diz que os mais
comuns são no sul da ásia e em zonas da
áfrica subsaariana mais de 100 milhões e
100 milhões de meninas vão ser obrigadas
é casar nos próximos dez anos na índia
25 mil mulheres por ano são violadas
isso significa uma violação em cada 20
minutos
embora as mulheres nunca lidera as
guerras são suas maiores vítimas da
violência sexual violação é usada como
instrumento de guerra um pouco todo
mundo de 2014 na nigéria o grupo
terrorista já captou desde 2014
pelo menos duas mil meninas e mulheres
72 milhões de crianças no mundo interno
não têm acesso à escola a educação 54
por cento dessas crianças famílias na
república democrática do congo que é um
dos piores países do mundo pra ser
mulher mas não escolham nomes nas 48
mulheres são viúvas por hora
quarenta e oito mulheres são violadas a
cada hora
esta estatística el salvador
o aborto é ilegal e mesmo que a mulher
corre risco de vida
nem vi a mulher viúvas são prescritas
são expulsas das suas comunidades são
abandonadas e assim a tradição manda e
portanto a única perspectiva de vida que
têm a partir deste dia e esperar que a
morte chega sendo que os crimes contra
os homens são os sírios contra as
mulheres é tradição as mulheres
representam dois terços dos analfabetos
adultos em todo mundo
a política do filho único na china é
autorizada para controlar se o
crescimento da população gerou uma onda
de assassinatos de bebês assassinatos de
bebês do sexo feminino 35 por cento das
mulheres do outro 35% das mulheres do
mundo já experimentaram violência física
ou sexual por parte dos seus parceiros
38% das mulheres de todo o mundo são
mortas os homens com quem tem uma noção
mais de 125 milhões de meninas e
mulheres 125 milhões de meninas e
mulheres foram genital eacute lavadas em
29 países de áfrica e do médio oriente e
pergunta que nos fazemos esse continuam
a achar que ele não faça vivo ser
feminista nos dias de hoje
a condição das mulheres no mundo
a luta pela igualdade a denúncia destas
atrocidades e tantos outros crimes
contra as mulheres façam profunda acerca
destas temáticas são luta no pequeno
ação no terreno ea construção de um
pensamento crítico isto tudo foi feito
por algumas mulheres também ao longo da
história que nos que foram também elas
muito corajosas que também elas nos
permitirão estarem espalhadas por todo o
mundo são as referências do nosso
feminismo atual acima do var agora está
em angela davis e espinho na era sarney
o otan kraft a sofrer e exista é limpar
casas foram elas e muitas outras que não
sabiam que a minha mãe acha eo
pensamento sobretudo abrir o pensamento
é para esta apresentação mas também
foram elas que nos iluminaram e nos
fizeram ver se o caminho e depois o
parto
a plataforma e projeto das nossas vidas
a marcar passo
é por isso que estamos aqui hoje é uma
plataforma que desafia a ser a
portuguesa por esta sala é debater se a
pensar sobre isso a refletir sobre os
números que acabava que acabaram de
ouvir mas sobretudo é combater e agir e
promover a igualdade de gênero ainda da
unidade numérica parte ponto pt
presidenta todos os dias o pensamento e
as feministas faça uma catarse uma
reflexão em conjunto
detesto muito diversificados de pessoas
acreditem das mais diferentes províncias
opções políticas credos idade mas que
têm em comum o objetivo de contribuir
para a construção de uma sociedade mais
justa a brincar parte também da palco as
mulhers ao talento das minhas a
criatividade a grandes profissionais e
que às vezes já nos aconteceu não tem
onde divulgar os seus sonhos o seu
trabalho o seu talento ele tem esse papo
nós somos fundadores deste projeto conta
com a participação de mais de 300
mulheres cronistas artistas com juristas
fotógrafas empresárias engenheiras
arquitetas desportistas estudantes donas
de casa políticas professoras atrizes
cantoras diz ter circo mais dias avod
filhas
esta é uma das fotos com algumas das
nossas mulheres capazes nossas capazes
de construir conosco outra falta também
é eu e rita
somos feministas desde que nos
conhecemos desde que vencemos com gente
como eu exatamente isto feminismo e esta
é portanto nós muito mais séria quando
ambas entrarmos pro para o mercado de
trabalho é e como mulheres ea nossa
imagem exposta publicamente
prevemos uma e outra trabalho porque
queremos ter filhos e queremos cumpri
los como mais podemos oportunidades de
progressão na carreira porque tem mesmo
sem ter opiniões em ter convicções e em
viseu as vemos projetos por cruzarmos
falar vai sim ser menos dóceis e
cúmplices para situações de injustiça
fomos consideradas algumas vezes por
bossi mandonas é porque temos capacidade
de liderança e as atividades romano
gentes da mulher no pior da figura
pública era mais ainda e as senhoras que
era muito muito bonitinhas e quanto mais
carro vinha em melhor hora nada mais do
que nada melhor do que estar a caminho
dos 40 partiram esta
e é aproveitar a nossa dignidade é
empenhe convicção e fosse um trabalho
bonito você trabalhar muito para o
projeto que é nosso mas que booth onde
está a mudar
nunca se falou tanto cinismo igualdade
de gênero falharem pra você vai formando
agora até já em moldes para acompanhar o
velho de igualdade e ainda bem que
existe imagina e uma mulher com hipótese
de tomar a casa branca e will i am
é o que o que é certo é que talvez um
dia não sejam precisas as cotas e este
dia extra o dia em que se lembra a
igualdade
talvez um dia não seja necessário curar
o dia internacional da mulher
talvez um dia os números rivais que nós
nos apresentamos aqui hoje e as
estatísticas básicas façam sua parte de
uma missão nos livros de história
talvez um dia a plataforma marinha capaz
de pouso num qualquer museu da igualdade
visitar a tumba de mil de mil das flores
livros e muito espantadas de um dia ter
sido necessário criar essa plataforma
talvez um dia talvez um dia e este será
certamente um dia muito feliz muito
livre muito inteligente mas é pra esse
dia é preço futuro que trabalhar
enquanto isso seria como dizia a sofia
em cairo e limpa não chega há um longo
caminho para andar de olhos fechados
este é o momento também é o vosso
momento e por isso a pergunta impõe-se o
que vocês vão fazer aqui não é
brincadeira não é ver um copo conosco eu
queria que fosse uma proposta supertaça
mas o que vocês vão fazer realmente
coisas saírem daqui vão voltar às nossas
linhas normais vão fazer de conta que
não a viram esses números e que não
conhecem essas realidades ou realmente
juntar se à luta pela igualdade de
gênero e assumirem
feministas sem medo da palavra tem aqui
um peso que toda a gente acha que ela é
uma coisa ter a palavra
vamos tentar derrotá la roux e nada me
entendo agora atrás do tempo 123 min
nita muito bem quanto a gente convosco
para mudar o mundo
até porque encontrou a estrada para
andar amiga a gente vai continuar e
encurtam registrada para andar bem como
também ventos imagem
a gente não vai falar isso para
acreditar muito obrigada times ou roxo